I in fourth of July holiday still a
couple of weeks away but fireworks are
already lighting up the skies across the
valley 8 news now reporter Kristin
Drummond looks at the numbers for us and
also the issues this creates around the
valley the county is already receiving a
number of complaints about illegal
fireworks and some tell me it seems to
be happening even earlier this year just
like a lot of fireworks late at night
like around like 10:00 and stuff this
year at six way sooner Clark County
staff report nearly 2600 complaints on
the ice by fireworks website between
June 1st and June 22nd substantially
more from the 258 complaints during the
same time period last year most of the
illegal fireworks use happened over the
weekend with more than 1800 complaints
between Friday and Sunday an interagency
campaign called you lied it we right it
continues to address the issue but the
explosions now are causing concerns
among certain populations that we're
already seeing an increase in of the
animals that are in the animal shelters
which sometimes that takes us a week to
two weeks to get those animals back home
or already's hearing increases from our
veterans it's very disturbing to many of
them the only legal fireworks in the
valley are labeled safe and sane those
are sparklers and fireworks that stay on
the ground not exploding in the air the
county and other jurisdictions allowed
them between June 28th and July 4th I
just asked everybody to do their part
and then think about somebody else the
county recommends reporting people using
illegal fireworks to the ice by
fireworks website you can find a link to
that on our web page 8 News now.com
Kristen Drummond 8 news now alright so
after Kristen's report we asked on
Facebook do you think enough is being
done to stop illegal fireworks and
obviously the big majority here 82
percent of people who participated in
this poll say no enough is not being
done and 18 percent said yes did he